thank you to expressvpn for sponsoring
this video more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
it's me ter Ericson alongside Aaron
hello Alexander that's my name you did
it you did it except he said hello in
between Aaron and Alexander my middle
name we're learning that today right
before we watch
jigsaw technically number eight in the
series that we are doing do not forget
do not forget to leave a like you got to
type in there and you got to leave a
comment that was how cool this movie is
how cool we are and also don't forget to
ring the
bell ring the
bell that's right and thank you to
prepper for helping us edit down these
videos and also don't forget we call you
super sexy if you join on patreon if you
get if you get on patreon you get super
exclusive highlights watch La with Greg
and with John but then with Le you can
sneak up with your entire whole copy
watch all of Jigsaw with me and Aaron
and it's so much fun we're so much fun
get on it okay do you got anything to
say before we watch this I'm I'm ready
to jig jig AA W he's ready to jig AAW in
the voice of the guy who's saying it's a
beautiful world okay great uh let's get
to
[Music]
it oh my gosh it's a new Lion's gate a
new Lion's gate hey hey hey hey hey h
pictures is the same no it's not Is this
different looks better updated better
they updated it but they oh blood after
Twisted pictures twisting up the Twisted
pictures saw when it got upgraded okay
okay
okay so I know one thing the only thing
I know about this movie is this one came
out in 2017 and the last one came out in
2010 oh my gosh that is is such a gap I
did not okay I didn't know that yeah
they waited a
[Applause]
while
rro this is already shot way better than
uh it's yeah it's got a Vibe but way
more cinematic yeah it actually feels
like a movie not a TV show
mhm
I'd hop in air vent oh the game than
smks the
spot
oh stop right there put down the weapon
can't stop it now right now
detective what five people are going to
die get hell out here
now cool car sick
whip we got some new cops new officers
involved they looks serious ready for
business all of you get back Edgar Edgar
what the
doing what's that for games are just
getting started I got to choose who dies
Target the remote if he moves to trigger
it blow it to [__] who's can throw in
you I'm not die oh [__]
[__] nice
shot and let the games begin well
clearly you did die yeah are you just
going to bleed out via your hand
yeah and he got the ab wound abom yeah
it's started oh we're ready all right
let's go
okay I see what you're doing there with
the puzzle pieces and the jsaw you think
you're clever huh okay movie they were
like title sequences we've got to do an
[Laughter]
upgrade oh cool we haven't seen buckets
before okay I like this reboot with the
bucket let's see what you guys got
going we've seen five people in a room
before but yeah not this specific
trap
hell
God it's going to be a probably a work
together thing yeah like uh like like
they got to yeah cuz it looks like the
puzzle piece is kind of a people like if
they can move the chain I don't know if
they can move the chain it looks like
it's a puzzle piece to work it out oh
God okay guys why is there always that
one guy right always just like loses it
I'm sure you're all wondering why you're
here salvation can be yours if you
planse yourselves of the habitual lies
which have brought you here confess the
truth will set you free I want to play a
game they're wearing the Trump buckets
from SpongeBob oh yeah lean light to
escape from this room if you can release
yourself from your demons you can begin
to shake the chains make the simple
blood sacrifice that I've requested okay
so the chains are going to shorten right
and then they saws them off
but I would just confess at this point
I'd be like here are all my sins all my
lies so sorry right what do they have to
lose you're already going to die oh God
what he just passed out what's going on
damn just getting dragged by the head
like
that well he's kind of in the right
position the the saws don't go down that
far oh
[Music]
true a little bit of blood an offering
of blood is what she's saying so like
oh oh nice oh it's a little bit of blood
an
offering okay at least she's helping
yeah this this feels more like a drawn
trap than a Hoffman trap
yes cut your finger off boy finger
bro oh God I don't want
it just do it ah
ah oh my God dum dum
o got a big big cut big cut people
always be freaking out how is homie
still asleep dragged by the head exactly
what happened to
him byebye buddy on they pull that [__]
where he comes back I know right and
he's just like partially cut up and his
face is half gone but he's still living
I wouldn't put it above his this
franchise at this point oh right like
he's the setup guy right yeah totally
why do you think he ask for you good
friends put him away twice edar mson is
a sociopathic methhead out of prison for
assault and battery armed robbery drug
doing nice guy with no hand or with one
hand now I've got him in a burbet induce
coma until he
stabilizes soing has to come down first
2 hours 2 weeks start the suspect list
with monson's known associates the thing
about this franchise is I don't trust
anything yeah I'm like so now we're
looking at every single character going
like who's part of this but but also
where's this in the timeline
true what do you want with us I want to
play a
game a
mitch what's your name Carly you said it
was a game and I hope for all of our
sakes that it is a game this game can be
one have they never heard of Jigsaw
before thought he was like this famous
killer are they going to be like this is
actually the first game
right why are these people staring at me
like that oh what are they
behind dead hanging Bucket Man don't
look back don't do it this is good she
going to scream yep yeah of course she's
going to scream no one else is screaming
but of course she's the one she's the
one
wasn't that super
[Music]
laser okay why does he only have a
diagonal head now I those the sky
sockets in there I think so I don't want
it that's rough someone's been studying
up on John Kramer okay copycat so we do
know hope not cr's been dead for 10
years okay oh look at us go okay hey man
how you doing good to see you you two
know each other Logan was our Medic in
FIA I'm sorry to hear about Christine
how you been man yeah um doing
well what is it
gross gross is what it
is oh we've gotten Advanced it's not a
key and it's not a cassette tape
anymore and then there were four the
games have begun again and they will not
stop until the sins against the innocent
are atoned for I will take care of the
next four you take care of the rest
sounds like John yeah it does oh maybe
because it's so Advanced that someone
can just speak into a microphone and
make it sound exactly like him like AI
yeah like voice
modulation oh are we getting Advance
spooky ookie oh [__] oh my God is that a
robot
[Music]
oh yeah it's definitely Billy but what
does he look like now is it Billy 2.0
yeah is he like old did they age the
puppet oh no he's Advanced he has
glowing eyes now dang he grew up he a
he's a little tall boy now
confess oh look it still says play me
with a cassette tape player I like that
vintage touch yeah nostalgic
he's conf F he conf
F oh dang it oh dang girl damn I I saw
her get a bike
once stole a kid 10 minutes after I sold
it to him oh sold the kid's bike he died
that's it that's all you did you sold a
kid a
bike I [__] what about you
sweetheart come on wa we lost our baby
tell me that this isn't
happening no no no that's infe is I
killed the hooker and to so hate my
neighbors not I need Mar
celing we're going to
hang who play the damn tape
Mitch
interesting why I I am certain that
there is a desire to point fingers at me
unless you turn that finger inward more
blood will be lost one who is not only a
liar but a thief and when you had a
chance to fix the harm that you've done
you chose to do nothing yikes this
criminal was injected with a poison one
of the syringes in front of you holds
the antidote one is a saline solution
the other an acid that will cause an
excruciating death yikes inject the
correct one failure to make the right
choice could result in death for you all
I ask you what is a life worth to you
okay so the blonde girl's a PR snatch
right so she's going to know what the
numbers mean check yourself for Marks if
he injected us that could be
marks why don't youall just say which
one it
is yeah you're right I'm come on now
then go
what are you doing it's okay it's
okay it's fine she also listened to the
tape right come on girl did you steal
purses yeah years ago but I I didn't
kill anyone you're Al I was broke okay
and somebody died but I it wasn't my
fault choose I'm going to stick them all
into you yo chill yeah
bro
$353 what does that mean what a life is
worth to me oh because that's all she
made from that steel
okay girl you better start injecting
that you already said which one it is
she just said it's
the damn this is
intense girl you you already know the
answer we about to die for this 323 yo
hit her with it come
on my God he's trying to swing like
Wolverine what just happened picked the
right one I
[Music]
guess oh or all of them or all of them
bye-bye honey oh my God is that what a
it does I can't holy
[__] oh I hate it damn wa damn she going
to explode oh my God oh my God oh I hate
it that's crazy God that's gross this is
why you don't do acid kids don't do acid
this crazy trip I can save their lives
you killed her he's
St both you need to chill what he said
also why are you guys all dumb Dum she
said literally said out loud 323 and
like no one thought to come on life is
worth
$353 that's what she said just dropped
the other two that's what she's saying
she's like that's what she said yeah
it's dummy Le dum dum this point is on
the inside of this could be the
combination Dental ID's bucket head is
Malcolm Neil his wife was murdered 5
years ago the home invasion per slit a
throat and made him watch oh man voice
was John Kramer matched identical came
back from the dead just because someone
is dead doesn't mean they can't have a
voice the recording says there are four
more potential victims also like the
lighting in this movie it's different
just thinking that it's just a little
bit darker it's moodier they're being
way more specific I think with the
lighting in this one than I've seen in
the prior ones I watched no yeah they
they took Extra Care and attention to it
yeah feel feels like a movie yeah it's
like a it's like a
[Music]
movie okay we're in the countryside
somewhere I I can't make out any
landmarks nothing oh God and I have the
feeling this story the specific one is
going to be more self-contained which is
what we were asking for too right yeah
cuz everyone from two through seven was
just like another chapter in the yeah I
like that we're sitting with these guys
right what's your sin ran sold Bad
Mortgages sold good Coke cheated on my
taxes cheated on my wife both of them
what's your story
lollipop G lollipop who wrote this
actually stabbed that guy right now why
am I being punished for something that
he did if he hadn't fallen asleep he
wouldn't have and
suffocated hold on honey oh my God he
roll run the baby oh my God he rolled
over and suffocated the babe this is why
you need a crib look there are two
perfectly good doors right here right
right so we go through the door that
leads exactly where he wants us to go no
thanks got you
[__] oh what's wrong Blow Pop does that
hurt it's going to be okay sugar
lumps
you got to cut into them get some wire
cutters there is some kind of
handle o bye-bye
leg care
care careful the thing I like about this
one is this is the first time since the
first or second one that the games felt
like it was like the primary plot yes
and as opposed to being like this
obligatory thing that they had to do
that they had to do this feels like yeah
I
agree oh
who oh is that a good thing that you
just nope guys look around in the
environment are there shears in there
cut the wires no you got to grab the
tape I Sav your like [__] grab the tape
you're going to call him a [__] and
he's going to try to grab a tape for you
leave him dude leave him in his dumb leg
you almost got it I'm trying dude you
got here got please don't fall in I
can't no okay it didn't
work we're fine oh my God that was so
intense no he's going to cut the wood I
thought I was going to cut he got it
okay get move away now there are no
shortcuts in life please forgive the
rather crude example I will make of your
decision to not follow the
rules pull the handle and you will be
set free what does he mean set free good
luck Lolly
pal they also found traces of aes's
disease it's a virus mostly known
because when swine get it Farmers have
to wipe out the entire sander keep
digging maybe I can track the virus to a
location Dr Nelson another one possible
jumper she is into him I was just going
to say that something going on here
having or about to have relations and
I'm like why is this plot added in here
there will be a reason that was some
intense eye contact right no link so far
to any of our
suspects see how she's like looking I'm
like what is what is her it feels like
there's something else with
it
like this is the injection point the
vein carried it all the way to the heart
where it's singed how'd you know it was
hydrop Floric acid saw a lot of it in
fuia puzzle piece
Jak what
why is this like why is that like that
why did you say it like that is it
what who said cut great moving
on how can you give a piece of the story
but also say I want to with the same
time like why does she have to want to
him I'm like how is this going to come
back I'm a good person I don't deserve
this I conf this I confess the this is
Up Guys somebody turned on a
TV hello you got to climb on his
shoulders yeah get on his shoulders come
on
now got
[Music]
it
O Okay so this give be a situation where
if he pulls it he gets his leg cut off
he could help them right yeah I don't
know
maybe oo it's digital now not in film
anymore Advanced right in the past you
have all put your own interests above
others now you will look in the mirror
and you will face who you really are you
cannot escape the truth one person who
can help
you if he pulls the lever before you
buried alive will free yourself to free
them do it
Ryan Ryan I just want to see an edit of
all of Ryan's facial
expressions isolated from the
context e what is it it's sand he said
they're going to he's going to bury them
alive what is that it's green oh it's
grain and initially I thought it was
going to be like like bloody fingernails
cuz I would be like that would be a
gross that's a lot of fingernails there
so many you get that from all the dead
[Laughter]
bodies get the
[Music]
handle come on bro let's do it where
were you the night Malcolm Neil got
murdered Home Alone can you prove that
do I need to yes cuz you got something
spooky going on with you got an off Vibe
yeah I'm sorry you have to stay so late
again Judy don't worry about it love you
too Daddy love you bye got a family loan
you have a website called jigsaw rules
no took some digging but it's a site
devoted to jigsaw we did a dark night IP
troll got a lot of hits from your
assistant yeah okay so you're saying
that Elanor bonnaville is our copycat
that's a fake name how did Elanor come
to you she saw out the department I mean
3 months ago she was offered a job
running the show at the Cleveland City
Mor why didn't you take that this is a
blood sample a per taken a decade ago
it's an exact match whose blood is it
John Kramer well she would have access
to that if she's a morg person but I'm
like she's too easy like they La it so
thick but here's the thing if he died 10
years ago how do you have his blood you
know well he probably took his blood and
stored it somewhere right I'm going put
past John to go here keep this right for
a future future use or something so you
can clone my body
yeah what you were so close you oh you
screw you you are going to die yeah good
now we decide now he gets buried to life
right he's watching the whole time Mr
Blow Pop you could have chose to save
them he failed the
[Music]
[Applause]
game oh whoa whoa okay just go
underneath inter
resting yeah hide under the
sand
oo s was
close sky this is facial expressions out
of context are really funny yeah
[Music]
o I hate this guy so much he sucks I'm
like really you Su you are the suckiest
suckiest person that ever lived who's
going to save him even though it's going
to sacrifice his
leg finally you did it good job buddy
damn at least it looks like a straight
on cut it's a clean cut man right little
pieces little
chunkies
ooh whoa damn nice nice catch of
yourself why didn't you tell me about
the job offer in Cleveland cuz you would
have told me to take it yes yes you damn
right I was it's complicated we are past
complicated and bucket head was strung
up I was at my um Studio your murder
Studio you know about the jigsaw fan
website whatever the doing on that
you're going to find out about
everything they think I'm involved only
with you
intimately why do people leave no only
leave the do open the door open nobody
does that even open for a pig mask come
on oh it's the cop it's the black cop
it's the cop follow
them he going to die though I feel it
yeah he kind of gave Vibes that he could
be in on it right yeah but I also thing
that's the mistrust of this franchise
yeah I should warn you turn the lights
oh it's probably just
Studio she's a fan
girl oh okay yeah that's the one from
two cop open oh that's that's one that
back in the yeah four no five cuz he has
his head on the top she's a collector
yeah hey A girl's got to have a hobby
that what you call it have a stamp
collection that's a
hobby the mouth clamp from 2 and seven
John Kramer designed this trap for a
game that took place before all the
others they found the plans in his lab I
built it myself none of Kramer's victims
died in any device like this maybe the
bodies were never found and maybe it
never happened what are you doing with
all this stuff you got the old school
camera oh sneaky sneaky eeky with the
glove
on maybe it's our primary cop the blonde
guy and that's why he's so
weird oh are they working
together oh damn hell happened to you
see in a saw game are we going to be
like he was in a game feel like he would
have said something in the last in the
last part the commissioner wants to see
jigsaw remains wants proof he's really
dead said he wants to calm the people's
fears are you serious chasing a dead man
he's been dead for 10 years come on now
is all yours I'm going to follow up on
these
[Music]
right oh he's a veteran so maybe that's
why
okay kidnapped oh
interation severe
relapse he's still
[Music]
breathing says my name says his name
says his name when no one is around you
say baby I love you while we playing
games
play it for him you've admitted to
selling a boy a
motorcycle
$600 for a bike that you listed in
excellent condition even though you knew
the brakes were faulty and in return you
delivered him to his end always test
drive wow he was my nephew before you bu
he's nephew the device you see here has
a unique power source it's the same
engine that Grace the bike you sold my
nephew oh wow I assure you the brake
lever for this one works
perfectly avoid the dangers around you
hit the motorcycle brake handle and the
motor will
stop would an elaborate
trap oh this girl is literally the only
one putting in work trying to save
people the entire time I'm just going to
say it literally no one else has tried
as hard as her she's
[Music]
MVP also there's no way that could be
Jon's voice if that's his nephew and he
died 10 years ago like his right that
looks like has be someone we already
know yeah within this
movie
grab it grab it grab it grab
[Music]
[Applause]
it
oh waa he got scrambled up oh boy oh boy
should have grabbed it there he goes but
also did he stand a chance inside of
that trap no I got oh God this freaking
guy pulled a Houdini nobody saw [__]
just cr's casket on
now it's not going to be in there it's
just a billy puppet what if it's that
box did we ever see what oh we did what
if another in the
bo you can call off the hunt for good
are there no cameras in the hospital
apparently not in this movie apparently
not in this
reality oh this is hearkening back this
feels like
two
there were two there were two I'll tell
you everything I know I know who did
this and you do too who found the body
at Elanor studio right he did put up
like a good act with like you you let
him go who ordered the the targeting of
the remote if he moves to trigger it
blow it to [__] everybody targeted the
trigger but did anyone actually see what
howerin was aiming
at do you think your partner knows that
you're with IIA internal
affairs's trying to frame me I don't
even know what he's got against me you
know you called him out for screwing up
slam down cases said he was a a [__] in
the Press twice no I said he was an
impulsive
[__] what kind of firearm do you use
Glock 22 9x19 Parabellum that's to Glock
17 now I'm starting to feel like he
maybe did it I'm like there's no way
it's this easy it would make sense for
him to be taking photos you have to see
a pig mask too I don't know how how that
body no no no it's okay they don't think
it's you or me I think I know where the
game is being played that's great let's
call it detective no you get off on this
[__] Logan of course I do this is a
chance for us to save lives so we're
going to take out a serial killer with
what our cunning intellect no our sexual
tension that only she's really ramping
up right in this film
she's carrying it on her
back
[Music]
yeah I'd be like shut the up dude like
let me
Focus oh my God he's
[Music]
outside yeah we got it
oh I hope that wasn't acid it wasn't
that's no going put her to sleep not yet
if it is that cop though it's kind of
lackluster
yeah it's too it can't be can't be can't
it well I guess we'll see right here if
they're going to reveal to obvious I
guess that's not JW
it right they bring him back to
life they cloned him oh my
what what the actual what did he get
cloned what did he get cloned does he
have a twin brother this is [__] is
he a triplet there's no way hello Anna
you died you holy
died oh my God oh my God you're about to
play a game this makes no sense it's a
final test I already passed your test
look at my leg that wasn't your test t l
this you want me to show Mercy you
hasn't taken even a single step toward
confessing you who's responsible not for
one death but for three you had stage
four cancer with Reckless deceit started
in high school
wor I did it but so long ago I want to
live as do I Ryan but things happen were
it not for a careless mistake by a
resident at the hospital I was in oh my
God they made my cancer could have been
diagnosed a lot sooner yeah please
explain this simply the wrong name on an
X-ray oh I knew it they were like they
were were giving you chemo are you going
to say he never had cancer yes that's
what they're this is so dumb John you
know
me it was the wrong
oops we were neighbors Anna and I Anna
and her husband Matthew were so kind so
supportive I thank you for that those
are better days for you weren't they H
that was a cool shot with the mirror I
know the two of you didn't always get
along but to have to endure that tragedy
the death of a child and he wouldn't
have rolled over and uh suffocated your
baby that is what happened right on
him she didn't oh she lied she killed
the baby yeah is it going to be like
shaking baby
syndrome
[Music]
I don't want to see her do
it she K the baby oh
god oh rough okay so you suffocated your
baby it could make a person go
mad that's straight up cool yeah so you
killed two people
technically I'm not going to do anything
you have to Simply assume
responsibility for who you are did John
just have this just another house and he
just watched the this okay I it's all
like right now that I don't like it and
I'm like oh they just switched up the
names also he got chemo he literally
practically like give me a break
y'all this is the worst I would like I
would be happier if they were like they
cloned me before I died right he
literally died yes what is so dumb well
it looks like somebody's here you sure
you want to do
this oh man that's why I'm like are they
pretending that that they're pretending
like didn't exist I bet so he just let
his wife die maybe this is just supposed
to no cuz they're saying it took 10 he
died 10 years ago right there's no
rational explanation for anything sorry
I'm going through it right now they're
going to have to say that he was cloned
and that's why he's still alive please
give some hell Mar [__] excuse cuz
right now it's all at the end is when
it's going to come out the math ain't ma
it was doing the movie was doing so okay
he was doing so well prior to this well
but right now
I'm fumbled the back maybe you can
recover but God
[Music]
dang okay we need to bring him in
now literally her face just reads like
I'm down to at all times and I'm like
why why why was no one like hey just
calm it down and do it during these
times it's literally all the time just
turn the wariness down just a little bit
just like a little it's
distracting it's cha she's so turned on
she's and needs another pair of
panties she sees John she's going to
lose it oh my God she's be like I
came
God I'm going to give you an opportunity
to turn it all
around is your key to
Freedom feel like they had to bring him
back cuz they're like well he grounds it
we're eight movies in and I think this
is the first time we've seen him
actively running the traps with the
people he's trapping because before
there's either Amanda doing it or
Hoffman and or he's just like um a body
on the ground but
yeah
also first movie without any flashbacks
yeah which I'm cool
with who Che the new Amanda you I have a
feeling but with John Kramer from the
start yeah lots of people are fascinated
by Kramer you know damn well I didn't
kill bucket head then who did right
behind to drop it it's him go on come on
put it down come on caramel clumps
yeah
all right I'm
going
oh damn whoa out immediately out please
don't because that's what he wants us to
do okay think about it I'm on the scale
no please don't okay just shoot
something in the room I think he wants
you to Save a Life my only key to
freedom is to kill you that's not
true he doesn't want you to kill more
people he wants you to learn a lesson
yeah so you need to explore the
environment more to see why I feel like
he going to backfire and kill her he
said
we yeah you're right called
it oh dang girl you BL off half your
[Music]
face a it's a reprisal of the first
movie cuz now he has one leg and the guy
from the first one has one leg
oh the key key
okay he your key to
Freedom all they had to do was look
inside the bullet all they had to do was
work together and do
it oh got him
gotcha oh another trap eh what have you
lied about what are your sins
confess hello gentlemen you came looking
for the game you found it these laser
cutters slice through tissue and Bone
like butter you both have an opportunity
to live if you admit to the reason that
you deserve to die how are you
alive let neither of us touch a button
we're both going to be in a minute first
I would just be yelling out everything
just come on out with it y'all I've done
nothing
wrong oo it was me I up I messed up your
x-rays oh oh God we're doing this on
purpose I'm so
sorry I confess I should have been there
for you I
wasn't would you have like cut his head
open yeah like when it went into his
face
it made the sound like it activated once
it got to his neck oh yeah so maybe it's
just like the laser light that doesn't
make sense cuz it just showed it hitting
the ceiling yeah then it doesn't make
sense I tampered with evidence I I I
took bries I put innocent people
away innocent people died because of me
I did
it is the ceiling going to fall on
top
what's a he was in on it the whole time
it didn't make sense
okay yeah knew it didn't make sense yeah
okay you're work
you I am here and With a Little Help
from you no one will ever suspect
it 10 years ago in this very
Barn a game was
played oh
oh the bodies were never
found jigsaw put me in that game because
10 years ago John decided I shouldn't
have to die over an honest
mistake I've recreated jigsaws game with
criminals from your failed cases jigsaw
put five people in his game I put in
three you and I are the last two why was
Edgar mson free he was a murderer but
you were protecting him because he was
your criminal informant Edgar mson
killed my wife okay I created a game
that appeared to be run by
gsaw oh like we talked about voice stuff
L 22 most cops do so Talon he's got a 17
okay we need to bring him in now because
Elanor will provide my alibi jigsaw put
the pieces of my life back together
again
what but then there won't be no
justice but there will this [__]
where the hell was he the whole time
together we built a
legacy what no the you didn't murderers
ists their victims appeared on my table
because of you oh major red consons we
love
that heit them like an
orange oh okay finally got the lines on
the face that's fun y okay is his face
going to
split like a flower oh looks like a
stranger thing yeah it does that's cool
I speak for the
dead oh my God big thanks to expressvpn
for sponsoring this video a real game
changer I've been using for years that's
right years so whenever they want to
work with us it's an instant yes you've
likely heard about expressvpn for online
privacy and security but there's more to
it than that however there was a very
real incident recently with Spectrum
Shing down my internet and contacting me
due to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my Express VPN on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a Global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it
whether it's kramas on South Korean
Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn
/re and you can get an extra 3 months of
expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reject to learn more
thank you
again this is not good that is not good
like he's so old and then they're saying
they're saying that he was from the
beginning there the whole time from the
very very beginning because he put the
thing down because now I was thinking it
might work
because he John looks very old so
they're they're saying like you got Kemo
and all this and then oh you found out
you don't actually have cancer so you're
going to live and you're going to live
old but it's going to be fine and here I
introduce you I messed it up sorry so
but it doesn't make sense because
they're saying he was in the very first
game from the very very beginning
exactly so they're saying that he never
actually had cancer so why was he dying
at all they give chemo then like are we
supposed ignore everything that's
happened in the other movies y'all this
is really bad oh my God like other
people have to be upset by this right if
you've watched all of the other movies
you have to go wait that doesn't I mean
it does I get they're trying to explain
it like okay it makes sense you're like
you mixed it up and he doesn't have
cancer and that's why he's still alive
but like it just seems like such a
copout to me it seems like a not a good
plot it's it's a cop out and not only do
they try to retcon this for the sake of
their own story but it retroactively
ruins the rest of them because you're
like oh he never actually had cancer he
but he was the guy who helped me so I
could do this to you now I was like
that's that's dumb that's really dumb
did I see the twist coming no not
particularly but just because you do a
twist That You Don't See coming doesn't
mean it makes logistical sense yeah I
mean they're trying to go yes this makes
this makes sense cuz he never had cancer
and that's why he's still alive but I'm
like dude we have so many other movies
that have set up this world and now
you're just you're basically ripping it
all out to give us this film exactly
which I don't understand I was like okay
so why go through all of that why you
have why do you have all these other
assistants because to carry on your
legacy what's the oh my gosh you guys if
you're listening to this on Apple or
Spotify I'm supposed to say this before
we got into our review but I got upset
set um please rate this episode and
don't forget guys to buy a t-shirt you
go to
www. reation shop.com you have to put in
the www there's some people are having
trouble getting T-shirts from reation
shop put in the www before okay and we
appreciate you so rate it high anyway
get back at it yeah yeah this movie was
uh not good I will say okay before I go
into it again yeah there's some
positives there is there is let's say
some positives the traps were very cool
very inventive this is the first time
since the first or second movie we're
focusing on a cast of characters that
are going through this this Peril uh I
know they've done it in other movies but
I feel like this is the most effective
they've done it since the second one
that being
said it just I don't know it didn't come
together once once they introduced the
fact that it was actually jigsaw the
original coming back that's when the
movie kind of lost me I'm like all right
they're going to need to do something
crazy to to win me back and even if they
they did try to do it or the when we did
get to the point where they tried to do
it it didn't work entirely like the fact
that he was at first I was like okay oh
no it was him this whole time oh the
games we're watching is 10 years ago
okay okay this makes sense nope cuz he
was there the whole time from the
beginning but it I don't know and then
there's no mention of any of the other
supporting characters like his wife or
Hoffman or Amanda it's just none of them
like how did they not how was not how
did they not go well we have to place
him now in the background he's the guy
you didn't see when Amanda was still
around or when the other detective was
still around who ended up being the guy
that this new freaking Mor guy was in
the background the whole time like right
like I would have Incorporated that
somehow but they just threw him in here
I think the thing that bugs me the most
cuz I knew that in the beginning I was
like we figured out or I was like we
were saying it must be a voice thing
like they're they're messing with his
voice and like it's now it's now time
here's his voice and someone else is
behind the scenes right which it was it
was more guy but the fact that they have
to connect him to John and that John was
still alive because he didn't have
cancer which he had for like two of the
movies right uh like three of the movies
I think or three of them he was dying
the whole time time you're saying like
yeah you would be you would be very mad
at him if he messed up your x-rays
because you were under chemo you're in a
wheelchair with oxygen on and in a bed
and you got your brain drilled into like
I'm just like what no no like it's it's
just there's some pieces that I'm like
but the the jigsaw it's not a good
jigsaw with that I feel like the puzzle
don't fit it doesn't fit very well I get
what they're trying to do but it's not
like wow that was great and oh we got
here which I had did we say number one
and number two we we I felt that and I
did really appreciate the game in this
that we follow the characters we finally
got what we wanted an isolated game with
characters where we just follow them get
to know them they have to work together
and confess and do all that but then
when we break out of it and we F and
what sexy lady cop where she just ran
off and we never well yeah so she is
going to be his Alibi because he was
there when the cop kind of came and
kidnapped him so sexy lady cop is going
to be in the next one yeah but wait then
who is the one that injected him to put
him in the trap in the first place if he
oh cuz he knocked him out and left
knocked him out and then he knocked him
out and then he went okay I see yeah
yeah oh man that's dis
disappointing I mean there's the fact
that they they waited seven years only
to go and then retroactively [__] up the
rest of their timeline is insane I was
like wow I've never seen a movie go and
willingly just go screw itself over for
the sake of a cash grap and oh man like
the the the effects are cool you can
definitely CH this is a different
director different creative team but man
I just don't think that they they really
landed it and it sucks because the it
was starting to get interesting it was
interesting in a way that we hadn't seen
in a long time and the gore was was cool
I guess and I don't know man the games
were cool I like I like the actors I
appreciated that we got an isolated game
with just the people we were following
them it reminded me a lot of like not
really one but two um which uh and the
as I was saying during it the lighting
and the way that it's shot much more
cinematic especially from the last like
they were like we would always say like
more TV movie this seemed like more
movie movie great but the thing that
makes me the most mad is when he sets
down the thing from one from one the the
thing the face clamp master from one
that's from one right that's from one
yeah cuz I was a manda's
trap so he was there before Amanda nope
there before H and why is he so young
then it's been 10 it's been how long how
does John I just what was he he's a
child oh my God are they gonna say
no because they showed
him are they gon to say that the Mora
guy is like a the kid did we ever find
that kid from one or two that was
trapped that we were
like I don't think he I think the only
trap he did for for this guy was the
walberg's kid walberg's kid no cuz he
wouldn't have no cuz that wouldn't make
sense CU he'd be an adult already at
that point that's what I'm saying but he
right so that's that's what makes me mad
by saying he's he's like from the very
beginning and he lays down the the Hat
always from the very beginning and it's
and the guy is the age that he is when
he lays down the number one hat that he
is right now and he's cutting off the
other detective's face right he has
an I need a timeline on it this movie
doesn't care about con but it makes me
so upset and everyone else should be
upset too because we should care about
that I hope y'all are upset cuz this
doesn't make any sense it's like a lot
of it was cool but a lot the ending when
you don't make sense with it it gets me
upset yeah I will say that they were
trying to be cute they're trying to be
clever with it right cuz they the fact
that the guy in the room with him turned
out to be the killer or turned to be the
new jigsaw the whole time that's a call
back to one him closing the seller call
back to one the fact that there was like
five of them in the room call back to to
two and to um I don't remember which one
it was when they were all had the
yeah four five four or five something
like that so they're like call backs and
references to previous games not to men
the room of memorabilia for some reason
that girl just has in a warehouse
because you know she can afford it with
that salary I don't know there's a lot
of stuff in here just didn't make sense
like I understand some of the intention
like May one of they wanted to bring the
the franchise back for a sense of
nostalgia but you got to at least make
it plausible if you're going to do
something like that because otherwise
you run the risk of ruining everything
you've set up with just one movie that
takes place years later because even
when we saw the detective in three or
four they gave us glimpses of like he
was in the environment where Amanda was
right we were like oh he has been there
the whole time this one just was like
and I've been there the whole time
here's the cap from one and then they
did the same thing with the last movie
with the the guy who was in the first
movie remember the the doctor
yes like but that's so it's a lazy pull
like why are we doing that we you got
we're better than this and there's a lot
of like decent writing and decent games
in here that I think is good like that
I'm like those setups and stuff like I
was really engaged but the the flip on
it I'm just like no we got to try harder
I think yeah I feel like most of them I
one thing I will say all the stuff with
the proper game games and with John
isolated was good Prime Time all that
stuff was good cuz it felt authentic to
the character that we established in the
past eight seven eight movies and I'm
like okay good but everything around
that the plot of the thing itself in a
hole does not work no it doesn't work I
was like okay I get it you want to bring
back the stuff CU you want to bring back
the the nostalgic feel of this franchise
Al so popular and it was cool that it
took us like eight movies but the fact
that we finally got to see the
culmination of a game with John being
the person talking to them at the end
yeah which was like okay that was kind
of cool yeah yeah I liked that aspect
cuz normally or we've come accustomed to
either being Hoffman there or being
Amanda there or he's just like red
written or something so you know I like
that I like that thing uh in a vacuum
but yeah overall this movie was uh
pretty disappointing some good stuff but
they just fumbled hard fumbled hard at
the end yeah I I mean will be curious to
hear you guys' thoughts I mean we are
fans of the franchise we've been
watching all of them back to back so
there is defin definitely huge parts of
this that we did enjoy but obviously the
reason why initially coming right out of
my mouth I was like this is not good
it's not because all the some of the
parts are bad it's because of at the end
and I just think that that is a it's a
weird sloppy flip that I'm like no we
didn't incorporate it well enough I
think there was a better way to do it
but
um I would give this one like a like a
six I guess I mean the games like the
games and the right like the writing in
the beginning all that it's like the end
that made me mad I'm just going to go
with six maybe maybe five and a half six
cuz it the the the the Cinematic shots
the lighting there was a lot of stuff
that added up but true you guys know my
feelings
now yeah what are you what are you
thinking I'm thinking I'm sitting at a
5.5 yeah yeah I mean it feels around
there right it feels around there
because there are some good elements in
here you know know what Scrat that oh
for the good elements the stuff that I
did like I'll give it a six G that's I
think we're we're together on that 100%
because the games the med in and it was
new stuff and I was glad we didn't open
up on on a head clamp again there was it
was really all new inventive games which
is interesting to watch they were so
close though so close cuz I'm like okay
you almost fixed it the fact that he was
still alive and the fact that these were
games played by John and then you
screwed it up by muddling up your
continuity and just man y disappointing
but yeah it was fun I didn't regret
watching it was fun and let's see if on
the next one we can get back to it maybe
we'll see what they what they do with it
because we'll have no idea but leave a
like on this leave us a comment tell us
tell us what you guys think whether you
like it or not do you agree with us or
not um and also don't forget to
subscribe buy a t-shirt go to the reject
uh the reject shop real rejects shop put
a www. in the front cuz you can get to
the website there's some people having
difficulty I hear um on the street and
yeah join patreon if you haven't already
we love you so much and we will see you
we've got two more left here so we'll
see you on the next one bye
[Music]
peace